the last thing i wanted to remind you
all to do is to dog food your own
marketing and that means that everyone
in the company should be
sharing and liking and following your
brand on social
and and wherever if you can't get your
own employees to do that
you're you're hopeless they're the most
powerful
and strongest advocates that you should
have um and
really thinking about how we're stronger
together
is the easiest way to get
the largest and in most exponential
reach
as possible is to use like everyone in
your entire network to help you lift
that message up
and so on that note i want to leave you
with how we
exactly did this recently so i put a
video up on
linkedin not that long ago when people
were saying that videos
could never thrive on linkedin i ended
up getting 18
000 views and the reason i did is
because
i have a channel that i started inside
my
our company slack where i will post a
link to something that i
wrote about and i asked my team to go
and comment on it
and then we ask other people to comment
on it as well it's super
unscalable right scale the unscalable
it's hard work you gotta go and
by hand ask other people to help lift
your message up
but as a result we got incredible leads
um from just this right
and it made it so that we hit our
million dollar a or our goal in january